えっ
そう
えきさいてぃお前はこんにちははじめ社長です今日紹介する商品はこちら
全米が震撼した新しい形の補修材ファイバーフィックスアメリカで100万個売れて
ますゲット俺見て g ニュースボーイになると音目の付け所が違ってくるんですよ
あぁこんな優れた商品を見つけるな俺だけだ
それじゃあアメリカからの輸入商品だ全米では100万個れるらしいんだ
あーじゃあちょっと細く見えることもああ
ちゃんと普通にありますまあアメリカっていうだけでなかなか激しいも作ってるわけ
ですよ
こっちから選んだね違う裏返しになってるんでちょっと読みにくいんですよ
なんで皆さん自分の選んでくださいごめんなこれは読んであげたいよ
難しいんだ
細かい事いいんで大事なのはここです見て分かる通り1世の足とか
パイプとかバットとかチャリとかもこのテープだけでくっつけたらもう元鳥っていう
そう合体型テープみたいにテープを水につけてこれ
ちゃべしゃべるってさぁちから本気で入れて穴掘るやつだよ
シャベルなんかに使うんですよって付けて時間経ってる
マーク作ったやつですいや正直疑ってるし俺はね
こんな風に騙されないよ今日はね俺が責任をもって完全補正というねこの結果俺はね
もう今日家からだけでぶち壊すから見せてくれアメリカの底力
pou dou dou 水につけると本当にガチで
ものがくっついて取れなくなるみたいなそういう報酬テープ
ですって今日はですね今週テープでくっつけたものを僕がね物工します
俺は出展者
一度
離れたものをどうぞ二度と
ブーブー言っ
これ小夏くっつけてその日あらもうこいつは方まずでアメリカキュッ
で全日本も号泣しますただ俺これで乗って壊れると a の愛は成立しないということ
俺が証明している
see here パカーンん
女官寿命つけて23回品テープに水をしっかりとした
まずでください
分かっ
それで水しかし3壊せないですよ
ブーブー s で水を20見つけて趣味は断ったら戸数部分をグードゥ違う焦ってるん
でしょ
ブーバーちょっとよえっ
me
とっています
うつを飾りこれでしょね
よし年目使って完全に守っ合体されております
灰皿す行こうと思います
さあこれでは終始ラクチェ
親指を受けている者数じゃ僕て帰るところだったと米3番目つけますはいトレーズ感じ
でしたのでこれで20分ほど待ちます
水をつけてちょっと伸ばせてくれておりますね
ブーブー s あーあえっ4ドッグ泥底1枚分ですチュロス
うんん
ブーブそう
チャンネル登録はこちらをクリックヘッドも水この増加
う
ああっって感じだったらグッドボタンお許してくれ
ちょっとテスト期間で切羽詰まってになりますやっとテスト終わってね春休みだったら
頑張るからさ